salut c'est normal aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous faire une petite vidéo
un peu particulière parce que j'aime
tout ce qui est particulier j'avais
envie de dessiner un truc qui s'appelle
un draw my life le principe est super
simple il suffit de dessiner sa vie sur
un tableau blanc avec des crayons et
puis de le filmer en france et en europe
peut-être traduire sa part ma vie en
dessin en plus ça tombe bien parce que
moi je sais vraiment bien dessinés faut
alors voila moi j'ai grandi ici dans les
favelas ce fait passer mon enfant s'est
retiré avec des [ __ ] de gueule
ouais non en fait c'est pareil du tout
moi ma vie est beaucoup plus banal mais
j'ai voulu raconter quand même alors
voilà je m'appelle norman j'ai grandi en
france
je suis né à arras j'ai grandi à lens
précisément à liévin bref j'ai grandi
dans le nord et grand père était mineur
dans les mines de charbon
un métier typique du nord de la france
par à l'époque on les appelait les
gueules noires
ouais même s'ils sont pas vraiment noir
c'est juste le charbon mes grands
parents et mes parents ont vécu dans des
maisons pour mineurs on appelle ça des
corons jeune fille issue d'une famille
typiquement ch'tis j'en suis fier [ __ ]
hockey ma mère était prof d'histoire géo
et directrice d'un collège et mon père
était directeur d'un centre culturel et
réalisateur de vidéos institutionnelles
bon là je les ai faits roues mais c'est
parce que j'ai pas d'autres stylo quand
j'étais petit j'avais la particularité
d'avoir une énorme touffe de boucles
blondes sur la tête
la coop des grands-mères 7 jours sur 7
un vrai plaisir les adultes mais bien me
dire oh ben dis donc on dirait boucle
d'or alors que les filles de mon âge
disait et regardez on dirait un mouton
parfait
du coup pour pallier à ça j'allais super
souvent chez le coiffeur et quand j'en
sortais les filles de mon âge quand
j'étais amoureux me disais hé regardez
on dirait un mouton rasé
[Applaudissements]
des fois mon père ramener à la maison la
grosse caméra de son travail sereinement
elle n'arrêtait pas de s'amuser avec
vous êtes vidéo marrante mais si on
faisait une sextape
j'ai eu un vrai du lieu dans les simpson
mais norman c'est pas possible voyons je
suis ta soeur ça marche
ouais j'étais en train de faire la voix
du mec qui mue parce que cette époque là
j'étais une sorte de gros adolescents 1
qui pu avoir une grande soeur ce a des
avantages mais aussi des inconvénients
vraiment de ma mère aimait bien recycler
des vêtements de ma soeur en me faisant
porter évasif je veux pas moins trois
gars au bois josi ok mais elle me disait
toujours mais ne t'inquiète pas ce sont
des vêtements mixte hockey et puis le
lendemain j'allais à l'école
et regardez le mouton tu la pin up et je
vous signale que c'est un vêtement mixte
hockey enfin une sorte de robe mixte
jetons lui des pierres après vers l'âge
de 12 ans j'ai fait de la musique
j'ai fait du saxophone alors ouais c'est
un instrument super classe mais
seulement quand tu en fais super bien
norman qui peuvent jouer un petit air de
saxo ou est tu as vraiment tu fais trop
pitié je te supprime direct de mes amis
msn et j'ai même été scout scouts
catholiques de france
on dirait pas trop un foulard de scouts
là on dirait plus un stéthoscope bonjour
je suis médecin
sauf que quand j'allais chez les scouts
bas je me faisais taper par les grands
est choisi par soit on fout là autant
berrer au ton iphone sexe n'est pas
encore bon soir jusqu'au jour ma mère
est intervenue et vous deux vous lâcher
mon plus direct sinon je vous demande et
c'est tout
[Musique]
et puis un jour ma mère s'est fait
attraper par un méchant tueur en série
qui s'appelle le cancer est parti
rejoindre les étoiles
je suis sûr qu'il me regarde de là où
elle est
ma soeur mon père et moi on est venu
s'installer à paris et ma france est de
plus en plus dégueulasse j'ai passé mon
bac avec mention
pas de mention et là je me suis mis à
jouer à un jeu vidéo en ligne mmorpg
pendant deux ans non stop
et puis j'ai redoublé et puis j'ai
repris pelé blanc ces deux années j'ai
quand même fait un truc pas mal c'est
que je me suis marié weight peut
paraître bizarre mais je suis marié avec
une elfe de la nuit
je la trouvais super bonne après j'ai
essayé de passer mon permis enfin j'ai
essayé le jour où j'ai passé le permis
aux inspecteurs m'a dit vous êtes le
pire conducteur de la planète terre
c'est nul à chier vous êtes un danger
public
ça veut dire que je lai j'ai commencé la
vidéo avec mon meilleur pote hugo sur
dailymotion attendez excusez moi voilà
comme ça
wen en fait comme ça non en fait tout
comme ça alors je rigole ça s'appelait
le velcrou en rapport aux chaussures
avec des velcros époque on trouvait ça
style est le pionner a été rejoint par
notre pote que marc un mec très très
marrant avec des très grosses lunettes
c'est à cette époque qu'on est tombé par
hasard sur d'autres gars qui faisaient
des vidéos comme nous sur dailymotion il
y avait six prises à l'époque monsieur
dream jérôme niel
à l'époque la ferme jérôme maximus cas à
l'époque les chroniques de la grosse
pomme
john rachid à l'époque macgyver du bled
et mr vie à l'époque mr vie ouais il
faut savoir que la gelée très très mal
dessinée je suis désolé et ceci n'est
pas un abat jour un certain bob et puis
avait aussi avant digne de 38,1 me
mandin pas venu à cette époque on était
en 2008
j'aimais tellement ça à faire des vidéos
que j'ai carrément la la fac leur
annoncer bonjour j'arrête la fac je me
mets à faire des vidéos sur internet
quaternaire
c'est un sport comme le badminton
c'est aussi à cette époque que je me
suis rendu dans l'association chats des
rues parce que moi j'adore les chats
depuis tout p'tit jaune toujours plein
je me rappelle je n'avais vu un qui
était super beau
avec un style un peu de pirates j'avais
envie de le prendre c'était lui que
j'allais prendre et puis tout d'un coup
il s'est mis a finalement je vais
prendre lui c'était cergy et puis un
jour en revenant dans un club de ping
pong
je me suis dit tiens si je faisais une
petite vidéo pour raconter ça et tout
seul cette fois j'ai mis ma vidéo en
ligne sur le site youtube
et là j'ai fait le buzz pourquoi parce
que je suis vent d'armes je suis en
parallèle à mes vidéos youtube je me
suis même mis à faire des one man show
exactement la même vague que dans mes
vidéos mais sur scène
certaines personnes me reproche de trop
souvent remercier mes abonnés le trop
souvent dire merci à ceux qui me
regardent
mais ces gens là ne savent pas il
n'imagine pas à quel point les
internautes ont changé ma vie
[Musique]
à